this is a place you've probably never
been Tsuruga Bay 70 miles southwest of
Tokyo off the coast of Mount Fuji we've
come here to where almost no one has
ever been to the bays deepest darkest
waters as we descend we take note of the
anglerfish it can walk across the sand
with fins that have elbows you may have
an SUV of your driveway but I'm betting
you don't have an ROV a remotely
operated vehicle that's gonna carry
cameras that broadcast pictures back to
our home ship now we're in the twilight
zone
where the Sun never shines inhabitants
include some exotic heels and a giant
spider crab the largest crab in the
world found only in Japan these crabs
can grow to 12 feet across they're also
known as the dead man's crab because
they've been found gnawing on the bodies
of drowning victims now let's go eat a
deeper this submarine can descend down
to 7,000 feet to discover creatures
never seen by man
these are the first known moving images
of the abyssal Cusk
eel a species of fish that can live
deeper in the sea than any other known
fish
these are Lantern sharks the tiniest
sharks in existence they're so small
they can fit in the palm of your hand
and finally we're in the right place at
the right time in a rarely seen
occurrence we capture a female chimera
in the process of releasing her eggs see
those twin sacs coming out of her body
what will technology help us discover
eggs